well if you are with Ethan this this
Thanksgiving you might just be a giant
blob of gelatin so this recipe was
making the rounds earlier on social
media primarily through the Washington
Post and that's how it was sent to me
and this is a a family recipe of a
gelatin dessert Thanksgiving jello and
we decided to make it just to see just
to see how it turn out put the gelatin
into a medium mixing bowl heat the two
cups of cider in a small pot over
medium-high heat put the remaining cider
in the fridge to chill
once the cider begins to boil pour it
over the gelatin and stir until
dissolved add the salt lemon juice and
remaining chilled ciders stirring to
combine refrigerate for one to one and a
half hours now you're looking for your
gelatin to be between the thickness
cough syrup and pancake batter great one
cup worth of apple chopped up one cup of
celery add to the thickened gelatin and
mix spray your mold with cooking spray
transfer the mixture into the mold seal
and refrigerate for two to four hours or
overnight
once the gelatin has fully set
transferred to a serving platter and
enjoy
okay so the recipe said a dollop of
mayonnaise for serving optional like
what yeah I don't even know like I mean
obviously you garnished with me in some
way or some mysterious reason for some
mysterious reason should we just should
we just fill no no I'll spoon outer
portions to put a little dollop of
mayonnaise on top all right so okay
gotta get got to get a good vertical
slice unfortunately I don't see that's
the part that's gonna it gets me this
it's celery ain't gotta gotta do this
it's a dollop
okay oh god I can't
I like Mayo I'm not one of those people
who like despises Mayo but just the
thought of that is kind of revolting
okay apple cider jello with shredded
apple chopped celery and a dollop of
mayo that Mayo does not do it any favor
why oh why why the mail these are not
these are not complementary flavors oh
okay oh god it tastes the mayor it it's
not play well with the sweet apple cider
at all it leaves an aftertaste like dish
soap so the apple cider portion at the
top which is just apple cider jello is
relatively tasty it's
applesauce i'm jello at eleven so I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna around that
mail that was why celery I just I guess
to give it a crunchy texture I don't
know that's all the celery was here
you've already I mean the apples
shredded I don't know even if we chopped
up the celery finer it would still give
it a crunch
I guess the crunch is a desired quality
yeah I don't my hunch I mean I guess
maybe because celery like it so it's
just kind of so bland on its own that
you can add crunch without him packing
with a flavor profile at all like I mean
I can tell if celery is in there taste
wise if I think about it but it's just
kind of there well okay would say add
more Apple than the recipe calls for the
shredded Apple in there is quite nice
it's just all chunky and yeah the Mayo
days was a trap the mayonnaise is a trap
it was a vile betrayal I mean we knew we
knew but I almost want to make this for
like a big family meal just to see how
it reacts cuz everyone will try and be
polite yeah say oh thanks it's when they
ask why I'll just say it was an American
recipe there you go um quite far from
the worst thing I've ever eaten but I'm
not gonna say it's it's terribly
Pleasant and I can't say that I'm going
to miss never having it again yeah
beside your jello portion is fine I
might really make apple cider jello for
the heck of it at some point in the
future that's that's fine
don't even know about that like it's
like the apple cider jello a portion of
it is copy is definitely Tommy but it's
not wowing me like it's not like ooh
that's really good and it was kind of a
kind of a hassle versus just I mean I
mean let's be honest
jello is not very good like even at it
the best it's just kind of it's filler
dessert so anything that adds hassle to
making jello is questionable so now we
need to invite some friends over like
tomorrow and force them to eat this yeah
invite everyone over for movies and then
just be like like hey I got some dessert
leftover enjoy happy Thanksgiving happy
American Thanksgiving
whoever said serve this with mail he's a
monster he needs to be stopped
it would be better actually yeah she's
gonna be giving me a lot better if you
took the celery out I don't get why the
song is in there it doesn't really do
anything like meaningful it's apple an
apple celery there for no reason and
mayonnaise there is an expression of
hate